[Music]
for centuries
these defensive towers protected and
preserved the svan
community of ushkooli the cluster of
villages
has world heritage status but
ushghouli's extraordinary medieval
architecture
is steadily collapsing
mossey's family tower was damaged in an
avalanche
he says the authorities promised to
repair it
help never came
we were celebrating a religious holiday
and the tower collapsed
thank god nobody was hurt but the
saddest thing is our heritage collapsed
with it
that heritage has outstanding value to
humanity
as defined by unesco before the pandemic
it brought tourism vital income
but tourism brought unregulated
development
like its towers which ghoulies value is
eroding
this neighborhood is emblematic of the
problems facing
usghouli you can see that breeze block
extension over there completely out of
keeping with its surroundings
this ancient family home has been
almost destroyed after a tower collapsed
and the tower is being rebuilt by the
government
but locals tell me that the quality of
the work
pales in comparison to the majestic
craftsmanship of their ancestors
george's heritage agency admits the work
has been
inauthentic but it also blames locals
for illegal construction
svan wright's campaigners say the
responsibility for protecting this
unique
culture must be shared
us in danger and it definitely needs the
attention of the state
no one else is responsible for our
material cultural
and spiritual heritage it's the
responsibility
of the country and its people
until then svans are taking matters into
their own hands
gear's tower contains family heirlooms
dating back
eight generations he lost patients
waiting for
experts to protect the building from
collapse so he did the repairs himself
ushkouli appears frozen in time
in reality it is falling apart without a
plan by the government
for this community its uniqueness may
not survive another generation
robin forrest dear walker al jazeera
and in the next part of the series we'll
be in senegal's nicola coba park
home to a unique species of wildlife but
its world heritage status is under
threat
we'll join those patrolling to protect
it that's from 10
gmt on friday here on al jazeera